let me ask you just for educational
purposes
what's the uh
can you please explain to me what web
three and the beef between jack and marc
andreessen is exactly did you see what
happened
sorry to have you analyze twitter like
it's shakespeare but
can you please explain to me why why
there was any any drama over this topic
first of all web 3
is a term that's used uh to refer to
you know the part of the economy that's
that's token finance so if i'm launching
an application and my ideas is to create
a token along with the application
and issue the token to the community so
as to finance the application and build
support for it
i think that uh
i think that that's the most common
interpretation of web3 there are other
interpretations too and so i'm just
going to refer to that one and i think
the beef
in a nutshell not articulated but i'll
articulate it is
whether or not
you should focus all your energy
creating applications on top of an
ethical digital property like bitcoin or
whether you should attempt to create a
competitor
to it
which
generally
would be deemed as a security by the
bitcoin community so i'm going to put on
my bitcoin hat here yeah right all the
tokens that have been if it's driven by
a venture capitalist was a security if
there's a ceo and a cto it's a security
all these projects they're companies
foundations or companies right if you
call them a project or a foundation it
doesn't make it
not a security they're all in essence
um collections of individuals that are
issuing equity in the form of a token
and if if there's a pre mine an ipo
an ico a foundation or any kind of um
any kind of uh protocol where there is a
a group of engineers that have influence
over it
then uh to a securities lawyer or or you
know to most bitcoiners and definitely
to anybody that's steeped in securities
law you're looking to say well that
passes the howie test
it's uh it looks like a security it
should be sold to the public pursuant to
you know disclosures and regulations
and you're just ducking the ipo process
right and and so
now we get back to the ethical issue
well the the ethical issue is
if you're trading it as a commodity and
representing it as a commodity while
truthfully it's a security you know then
it's a violation of ethics rules and
it's probably illegal well you're you
keep leaning on this let me push back on
that part maybe you can educate me but
you keep leaning on this line of
security's law
as if
it
with all due respect to lawyers
as as if that line somehow defines what
it what isn't isn't ethical i think
there's a lot of uh correlation as
you've discussed but and i'd like to
leave the line aside i uh if if the law
calls something as a security it doesn't
mean in my eyes that
it is unethical i mean there could be
some technicalities and
lawyers and people play games with this
kind of stuff all the time but i take
your bigger point that if there's a ceo
there's a project lead that's
fundamentally well that that's you is
fundamentally different than
the the structure of bitcoin it's not
that creating securities is unethical i
i created security i took a company
public
right
that's not the unethical part it's
completely ethical to create securities
you know block is a security all
companies are securities
the unethical part is to represent it as
property when it's a security and and uh
to promote it or trade it as such this
whole promotion
that's also a technical
thing because you're
i
like what what counts as a not as
promotion is a legal thing and you get
in trouble for all these things but that
that's the the game that lawyers play
there's an ethical thing here which is
like what's right to promote and not you
know uh
to me propaganda is unethical
but it's usually not illegal
20 years
right all the boiler room pump and dump
schemes were all about someone pitching
a penny stock you know selling swampland
in florida
and uh
if you roll the clock back forward 20
years and i create my own
company and i represent it as the same
thing and i don't make the disclosures
right you're you're just one step
removed from the boiler room scheme and
that's what's distasteful about it
um there are ways to sell securities to
the public but there are
but there are expectations
maybe
we could forget about whether the
security laws are ethical or not right i
will leave that alone we'll just start
with the biblical definition of ethics
yes don't lie cheat or steal so if i'm
going to sell something to you i need to
fully disclose what i'm selling to you
right and and that
that's a matter of great debate right
now and um
so i think that that's part of the
debate but the other part of the debate
is
whether or not we need more than one
token
like uh
we need at least one right we need at
least one digital property one is
because zero means there is no digital
economy yes and by the way you know
the conventional view of maximalist is
they think there's only one and
everything else isn't
that's not the point i'm going to make i
i would say we know there is that as
there is at least one digital property
and that is bitcoin
if you can create a truly decentralized
non-custodial
you know bearer instrument
that is not under the control of any
organization
that is fairly distributed
then you might create another or
multiple and there may be others out
there
but
i think that uh the frustration of a lot
of people in the bitcoin community and i
share this with jack is
we could create a hundred trillion
dollars of value in the real world
simply by building applications on top
of bitcoin
as a foundation
and so continually trying to reinvent
the wheel
and
and create
competitive things
is a massive
waste of time and its diversion of human
human creativity it's like
we we have an ethical good thing
and now we're going to try to create a
third or a fourth one
why
you